fruit juices dramatically increase the
risk of
cancer what is one thing that you
believe about
energy that most people don't there's no
human need for fruit just
ask an estimate if you want more energy
for your workout in the morning
the last thing you want is a
fruit smoothie
today's episode of model the monsters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles
i've done over 3 3800 split tests which
have led to results like taking this
five-year-old video
that was getting 250 views a day and
just by changing the thumbnail
it blew up to 15 000 views per day
you can get started on tubebuddy for
free at tubebuddy.com
evan and there he is talking about
country
how are you doing sir i'm all right how
are you
i'm great so if you guys don't know dr
gundry he is a
four-time new york times best-selling
author he is the founder of gundry md
i take some of this every single morning
i got a bunch of other stuff here the
the 5 000 i use of vitamin d
is uh was a new number to me so it's
crazy uh and he's the host of the dr
gundy podcast as well and he's gonna
be on to talk about health and his new
book coming up the energy paradox
welcome aboard thank you thanks for
having me
so tell me what is one thing that you
believe
about energy that most people don't or
might even find radical
about half the people that i've seen in
my practice over the last 20 years
actually admit to a diagnosis
of fatigue and malaise and that actually
surprised me when i first started doing
this over 20 years ago
and we did an informal survey at gundry
md
and the two number one you know wishes
and complaints
was to have more energy and and reduced
fatigue
so it's uh i mean it's a fascinating i
think
under underlooked and undervalued
epidemic in this country
part of the problem is that i think so
many
of my my colleagues in medicine
number one are overworked um and
they view i guess being tired or not
having a lot of energy is kind of par
for the course and particularly
a ton of my women patients are are
dismissed
uh by i think well-meaning health
practitioners
that oh you know you got two kids you're
working a job
maybe you're about to go through you
know the change
and this is all normal and just suck it
up and have another
double espresso and you know you'll be
okay
but that's actually not normal and i
know you're an advocate of coffee just
without the sugar and without the milk
uh or the was it one milk what's the
kind of milk we're not supposed to have
yeah don't have any one milk don't have
anyone else this is okay
so people are so used to being stressed
out and just
you know i'll sleep when i'm dead uh
i'll just take another shot of red bull
or something and and
from the book you said where was it how
to stop being sick and tired and finally
feel good again
so so what is top level some of the
recommendations you give people
that they may not immediately recognize
as being actually valuable for them
well some of the things uh you know i
started uh
talking about recently with lewis howes
and uh had just uh
a wonderful
throwback that i basically said
hey one of the biggest problems in our
diet right now is the amount of
fructose in our diet and
one of the places that fructose is in
our diet that people really don't
recognize
is the amount of fruit that we currently
have in our diet and i got
louis got a lot of pushback on letting
me say that
but this isn't something i just invented
um you know this this isn't my first
rodeo
yeah i didn't just get off the turnip
truck
um this is actually number one
my clinic results that i've published
uh looking at patients for the last 20
years
and manipulating their diet turns out
that fructose
which is the sugar and fruit is very
different
than glucose in how we make
energy out of fructose
and fructose is so interesting
in how it's handled so i got interested
in this years ago
when i was researching human evolution
and great apes and believe it or not
we're considered a grade egg
are the only time they ever gain weight
during the year is during
fruit season and even in the jungle
fruit ripens once a year
and grade apes eat fruit to
gain weight for the winter and winter is
a time of less food whether it's a dry
season a rainy season a cold season
it doesn't matter there's always a
season or two where there's
significantly less food and one of the
fascinating things that i
learned about fructose is its ability
to be made directly in our liver
into fat and that fat is triglyceride
the other thing that's unique about
fructose is that
normally energy production comes from
making atp adenosine triphosphate
and there's a mp and then there's
adp so adenosine monophosphate adenosine
diphosphate and then we make it into
atp what's unique about fructose
is that fructose actually stops amp
from being made into atp and instead
takes amp and makes uric acid
which is actually what causes gout and
also raises blood pressure and also
damages kidneys
so fructose actually hijacks
our energy production now
this wouldn't have mattered even a
hundred years ago
when fruit for humans was really only
available once
a year in summer and early fall
and we could use that like grade eights
to gain weight for the winter
but now unfortunately we have
fruit or fruit derivatives like
juices 365 days a year
and that's actually abnormal
now the other thing that
is scary is that the amount of fructose
in our fruits has been
maximized by hybridization through the
years
and for instance a cup of grapes
has anywhere from 22 to 25
grams of fructose in that cup of grapes
that give people an idea of what that
means
there's four grams
of sugar per teaspoon
of sugar so that let's take
25 as a typical cup of grapes
so let's divide that by four so there's
about
six teaspoons of sugar
in that cup of grapes and
yeah i mean six teaspoons of sugar
and we go well but grapes are healthy
well yeah they were healthy a long time
ago
when they weren't plumped up to be giant
you know sugar bombs and i'll use the
word sugar bomb again i'm sorry
blueberries when i was growing up a long
time ago
uh blueberries were these little bitter
things that
were so bitter that you had to have pour
a half a cup of sugar on them to make
them edible which was
great now they've been bred for size you
know i can go to the farmers market in
santa barbara and i can find organic
blueberries other size of grapes yeah
and blueberries now have a considerable
higher fructose content than ever before
in fact
the lowest fructose content
fruits are actually raspberries and
blackberries
followed by strawberries but blueberries
which used to be some of the lowest
now there's there's about 10 grams of
sugar
per per 100 a cup of blueberries now
okay so is is the recommendation
moderation is the recommendation just
no nothing until you know my initial
book uh dr gundry's diet evolution was
give fruit the boot
first of all there's no human need for
fruit just ask an eskimo
um the idea that you know and
believe me or some people call me the
father of the carnivore diet because
in my quest to get lectins out of
people's diets
the obvious ultimate lectin and
elimination diet is the carnivore diet
because you don't eat any fruits or
vegetables
and i'm not the father of the carnivore
diet by the way
uh but so the idea that we
have to have fruit in our diet is
is first of all not true and the idea
that we need fruit every day in our diet
goes against any hunter-gatherer society
in our society up until the last few
years
the honza who have been studied
extensively
only eat fruit during season
and when they eat it they eat a ton of
it
and you know all of my keto colleagues
do you really think that our ancestors
when they found
a beehive or they found a fruit tree
says oh my gosh i can't have this fruit
i'm not going to gorge on it because i
have to stay in ketosis
i mean really of course not remember
we're a fruit predator i like to remind
people
the reason we have color vision and
your dog doesn't have color vision is we
are a
fruit predator we're designed to
eat fruit and we're designed to
recognize
from the plant when the plant actually
wants us to eat its fruit when its
babies are protected
and the cool thing about fructose is
that fructose doesn't initially raise
insulin and we can eat
tons of fruit without getting full which
if we were fattening up for the winter
would have been a really great idea
the other thing to remember is
two-thirds of our tongue has
sweet receptors and that's why
when we found fruit it would have been a
really good idea to just gorge on the
stuff
and so i'm not anti-fruit and in fact
all my books
please you know have fruit in moderation
in season and please season is not
365 days a year so we're fattening up
but there's no winter
yeah and you know sadly
the british medical journal recently
published a
long-term study looking at
the correlation with sweetened beverages
including fruit juices directly
correlating to the incidence of cancer
in a 25-year study and even fruit juices
dramatically increase the risk of cancer
and you know why
because first of all you know let's go
down
you know i live near san diego my
parents retired in san diego let's go to
the san diego
zoo and look in all the cages and you
won't find a juicer
in any of the cages and
because an animal doesn't doesn't drink
juice so we're unfortunately
mainlining juices
sugars that we would have never before
you know one of my podcasts speaking of
like
covid one of the things that's
fascinating
is that fructose in orange juice
dramatically suppresses the ability of
white blood cells
to eat viruses and eat bacteria
for up to five and a half hours after
you drink a glass of orange juice
so that the idea that these things are
you know health foods has
unfortunately um
[Music]
it's just unfortunately uh incorrect
you've talked a lot about how diseases
start in the gut uh how do you get your
gut tested i i did they do biome test
a couple years ago they now are out of
business
uh maybe questionable science or not uh
but how do you recommend people actually
test to see if their gut is okay or not
yeah so you know hippocrates uh
basically
um said that all disease begins in the
gut
and that was 2500 years ago and he was
absolutely right
he didn't have the human microbiome
project too
but you know the longer i've done this
now um for instance if you had asked me
15 years ago what i thought about leaky
gut
i would have told you it was
pseudoscience and voodoo
but now because you can test leaky gut
and thanks to the work of
among other people dr pithano from
harvard
you can you can test for
the breakdown of the tight
junctions that hold our intestinal
barrier
together i use a company called vibrant
america
they um a few years ago they came up
with these tests
i don't know who their marketing person
is maybe you could advise them but
they're called
zoomers yeah okay stupid name
so the original test was called a wheat
zoomer and it looked not only
for markers of leaky gut it looked for
celiac markers
but it looked for all the components of
wheat barley and rye which
among other components are gluten and
gluten happens to be a lectin
but then they expanded those tests to
look at corn
i recently published a paper in the
american heart journal
that 70 of people who are sensitive to
gluten cross-react with corn
and they actually cross-react with the
proteins
and think when they're eating corn that
they're eating
gluten so
yeah yeah 70 and then they developed a
lectin zoomer imagine who they did that
for
and then there's a milk zoomer and there
is a egg zoomer and there's also
a really cool test called a neurozumo
and one of the things i've learned
from the neurozuma is that
if you have a leaky gut there's a pretty
good
chance that you also have a leaky
brain and as bad as a leaky gut
sounds let me tell you if you've got a
leaky brain
that's not a good thing normally we have
a very
tight blood-brain barrier where
very little can get across into our
brains
in fact it's another subject um
that's another subject in the
energy paradox where
ketones are what our brain
uses because normally
our mitochondria if they're working
properly can
shift from using glucose as the fuel to
burning free fatty acids as a fuel fat
from our fat cells
unfortunately the blood-brain barrier is
very
difficult to get free fatty acids across
our blood-brain barrier it turns out the
mitochondria in the brain
can burn free fatty acids but the
blood-brain barrier pretty much
heats them out ketones on the other hand
can get across the blood-brain barrier
so
one of the fascinating little tidbits
that people
learn in the energy paradox is that if
you're doing everything right
for 12 hours out of the day we will
normally produce ketones in our liver
for the sole purpose the sole purpose
only
of letting our brain have something to
eat when we run
out of glucose but what most people
don't realize
is that brain is such a glucose
hog that even at full ketosis
the brain can only get about 70 percent
of its energy needs supplied by ketones
and it still requires about 30 percent
from glucose from neogenesis from the
liver
all right wonderful nerdy stuff so
i know i like it i like it let's go even
nerdier i want to ask you about
acromensia so
well i know you've talked about a bunch
about it people in the arts may not know
what that is but
uh when i did my you biome test i scored
great except for acromancy which was low
so now i started immediately like what
is acromensio how do i how do i get more
of it in my system
i tried to sign up for a test that they
were doing out of belgium patrice
canning
was had the first pasteurized acromancia
supplement
um that they run experiments with it's
not i can't i couldn't get on and it's
not
you know public consumption yet but uh
how do you get more acromensional
maybe for the audience what is
achaementia so we're not super nerdy now
but then how can i every carmichael get
more akkamancia
in my gut so
so acromancia mucinophilia
is a bug that actually
lives in the mucous layer of our gut
wall and the mucous layer
by the way absorbs lectins and
mucus is a sugar molecule
a muco muco-polysaccharide that absorbs
lectins and keeps lectins from getting
to your gut wall and makes leaky gut
so acromancia mucinophilia means mucous
lover
and the more mucus that you make
interestingly enough acromancia
the more mucus it eats it
stimulates our gut wall to make
more mucus and so it's this
you know it's just this love love love
relationship the more mucus it eats the
more
we make so anker mancia
actually loves uh to
have us fast and here's what
it turns out that the more you fast the
more the
other bacteria in your gut
have basically nothing to eat and
it has access to mucus and can stay
alive
and so it in a way uh
fasting for over 24 hours
is a quick and easy trick to increase
your acromancia but the other trick
which i think is even
more potent is to
give acromancia the foods that it likes
and these are
prebiotics so everybody knows
probiotics so acromoncia yeah so
acromancia is a
probiotic but you
right now can't swallow acromancia there
are some
formulations that are coming up but
nobody's been able to really get it
get it right but they're there in your
gut they're always there
and you just have to give them what they
want to eat
and so give them prebiotic fiber and i
formulated pre-biothrive
specifically to give gut bugs
the stuff that they want to eat
now there's a really fascinating couple
of studies that i
have in the energy paradox that takes
this kind of
another step um and i think
this will be an easy way to explain it
we've always thought
hunger comes from neurons in our gut
sensing lack of food and it sends a
message to our brain
and our brain says oh my gosh you know
there's nothing coming through and you
should be hungry
well some researchers in china said you
know
we now know that the gut microbiome
sends tons of messages to our neurons
and sends tons of messages to our brain
that i talk about in the longevity
paradox
and what i did in the energy paradox is
let's take this one step further perhaps
we've been naive that these
microbiome just kind of talk to neurons
maybe they control our hunger for what
they want to eat and this has actually
been well worked out we know
that there are obesogenic bacteria
that we used to think we're good at
extracting calories from the foods we
eat well we now know
that the obesogenic bacterias hijack
your brain and says hey we need
simple sugars and we need saturated fats
and that's what we want to eat and get
it to us
and so they actually take over our brain
so chinese researchers said
wow if that's the fact then what if we
took a bunch of volunteers and put them
on either a seven day fast or a 14 day
water fast and we give them a hundred
calories of prebiotics
a day that we cannot digest
and but the bugs can digest
and let's see what happens to people's
hunger
and lo and behold what they found was
that these prebiotic fibers which
again we got no calories from it these
people were able to do
seven 14-day fasts without hunger
because the bugs were being fed
and it turns out they were absolutely
right so this
is a microbiome centered
theory of hunger and it makes
so much incredible sense now that we're
learning the
power of these microbes
to communicate their needs directly to
us and
the energy paradox is all about this
entire
new science that's been discovered of
the
actual language that bugs
communicate to our brain and
i mean talk about nerdy fun stuff
uh i mean it's like a kid in a candy
store
finding out and i'll use another example
look let's
you know we've been sending radio waves
off into the universe for
50 years now and you know we've been
saying hey anybody out there you know
are you getting our messages you know
this is what we look like
and you know hey you know give us a give
us a buzz
so this is like all of a sudden you know
on our radio telescopes
we get a message back oh yeah you know
we've been watching you guys for
millions of years
and guess what we live inside of you and
you know thanks for figuring out we've
been trying to talk to you
and it's like
i love it so i mean this was given to me
by a friend who i helped with his
youtube channel
and i've only had it for about a week uh
it was even before we knew
you know this was i was gonna talk to
you he didn't know and he said you have
to get on this
it'll change your life and this has what
30 calories or something
in it that i have in the morning and
i've only been on it for about a week
but at night i'm not even that hungry
last night my wife is
saying hey you want a second helping do
you want some snacks even healthy snacks
like
i don't know feeling kind of good i
didn't i didn't associate it to this
but um that's great now now i know the
reason we gotta
make sure i keep taking it um wow wow
i mean it's crazy how time flies when
you're having fun i appreciate the
insights and the wisdom and the
knowledge
um for people who want to dive into your
world pick up energy paradox
listen to the podcast uh you know
obviously here on the ig live but on my
youtube channel afterwards
we'll link everything in the description
where do you want people to go next to
learn more
well so they can go to dr gundry.com
they can go to my supplement site
gundrymd.com
i've got the dr gundry podcast we just
released
the dale bet bredesen's interview from
the end of alzheimer's program um
i've got two youtube channels you can
find me on instagram it's hard to avoid
me
i love actually we gotta we gotta talk
about youtube channel we gotta get that
to millions of people people need to
hear this message
yep yeah let's let's get it out there
well thank you for the love the time the
energy best of luck in the new book i
can't wait to get my hands on it march
2021 right march 2021 looks like the
date
and uh but um if you want a preview of
that book
the longevity paradox which was my
most recent bestseller uh gives you a
lot of the uh
teases for the energy paradox
but i'll give you one last thing if you
want more energy for your workout in the
morning
the last thing you want is a
fruit smoothie and that ought to
light up the phone line what what what's
what do we have instead so you don't
want to have anything
uh there's nothing there's beautiful
data
that a fasted human produces
more energy and has more energy
than a fed human before exercise
and think about this from an
evolutionary standpoint
if we didn't have any food
and we needed food and
catching food or finding food was
essential for our survivor
survival we would actually have to
produce more
energy at the last second to do that
and so there's there's very good data
that not eating before a workout
actually increases your ability to work
out better
then what's really cool is that if you
wait about
20 minutes after that workout and then
take protein with a little bit of
sugar and go ahead and put a little bit
of fruit in your smoothie at that point
you will actually not only increase
growth hormone for muscle building
but you'll actually decrease insulin
resistance
which is what we want uh long term so
wow yeah don't don't have the
pre-workout shake please please please
please
will it help me regrow my hair anything
i can do for this doctor hey you know
that's
that's a great question uh not to
try to have you do something but i do
make a hair growth formula
and i i used to have a bald spot in the
back my head i don't have it anymore and
i grew up
my son-in-law's hair back so
all right well i got i got all i mean i
got we got this let's see what i have we
got the vitamin d
we got the total restore thorough
resource a great gut healer
yeah we got the 24 strain yeah
yeah we got the vital reds
polyphenol oh the polyphenol rich olive
oil you got the pearls
and and the mushroom blend ah the
mushroom one of the best ways to pop up
your immune system
is mushrooms cups a day or something i
heard you say that that was crazy
yeah it's just a little dropper full i
put it in my coffee every morning
you can't taste it okay so i this is
next but but i gotta get the
what's what's the hair loss one i'll
give it a i'll give it a try what do you
got what's it called
uh so it's it's actually it'll restore
it's a treatment for your scalp but we
also make a supplement
that grows hair from if you will the
inside out
there's fascinating data that there are
probiotics bacteria that actually
make you grow hair
imagine that sign me up sign me where's
the newsletter or the uh the product for
that i am on it
just go go to gundry md and look at hair
care products
and you'll find it all right well thank
you for the time i know we went a little
bit over but appreciate your wisdom
and knowledge and energy and i'm still
pumped for the new book and can't wait
to see it when it comes out
all right thanks for having me all right
much love if you want to change your
life in the next 30 days check out my
free training below
or if you want to see the top 10 rules i
did on dr steven gundry check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe and i'll
see you there